I am so honored and humbled that you all
came here tonight to our pause oh yeah
get ready little monsters because et is
taking you inside Lady Gaga's house
laboratories lunch I welcome you to our
home make yourself comfortable
drinks make up whatever you like
mother monster through her epic bash at
the Barker hangar in Santa Monica on
Monday night and let me tell you it was
bananas but would we expect anything
less
yep Gaga was seen dancing her little
heart out and she turned into a DJ
taking control of the ones and twos
[Music]
but it's this next video that I love the
most
[Music]
she's literally chugging that champagne
straight from the bottle can we get a
slow-mo of that
this also happened et has learned that
Gaga's rumored new boyfriend Dan Horton
was not there the night was just all
about Gaga and a fun fact
Haley Bieber and Kate Bosworth were on
the RSVP list but sources tell et that
neither actually showed up to the party
other celebs who did show up Evan and
Ashley Simpson Ross Patrick Starr Tyler
Oakley and Whitney Port
and we're told guests enjoyed snacks
like grilled cheese and cotton candy
of course the sweetest part of the whole
night was Gaga's nearly ten minute
speech I have always even prior to my
career wanted to spread love around the
world at first I found that way through
music but it was the discovery of makeup
that helps me transform into the artist
and person I always wanted to be for me
I learned to love myself from the
outside in one second though how is she
standing in those shoes truly epic Gaga
also made sure to thank her mama I was
first inspired by my mother and got
candid about her own personal struggles
I'm overcoming obstacles
I'm dealing with my own mental health
issues around Fame and finally being
able to really show up for the world the
way that I want to in the way that I
believe that
I love gaga so excited for her new
collection let me know if you'll be
purchasing anything and for all the
latest on Gaga keep it locked to et
until next time I'm Katie crafts and bye
for now